[Music]
to change the conversation period about
the aspirations not to be a millionaire
it's to be you got your prospective
happy don't you want to be happy
[Music]
but this is neither because no one
becomes a millionaire nine-to-five can
you say it all the time and I'm hustling
getting up at and honestly man wanting
to change on a set meticulous advantage
we need to change the conversation
period about the aspirations not to be a
millionaire it's to be happy
Amen for real like you're not happy you
are you meant a 16 year old you being
like I'm gonna go to Peru and I'm gonna
[ __ ] video and I think the universe
because for a friend I won't put in my
life too like I had the money or or
everything was dead that I always wanted
but then I took north happens I was not
happy I'm enough to know my radio
station my 29th and agenda is to make me
happy like for you to say as your and
you're doing it subconsciously like
you're not not everyone's a militant for
you to say not everyone is happy at 27
if I can replace the word millionaire
with happy and I'm crazy I think I can
pull it off what do you do Gary one
let's say you're at a location or you're
a point in your life that you're
obviously you need you need to pay bills
but you're no longer happy what what do
you you need to change your bills okay
okay you need to not buy a fresh [ __ ]
hoodie you may need to move into a
shittier apartment I'm being dead
serious one of the other conversations
I'm having is change your bills okay you
know if you're not happy but you got
bills why don't you look at your bills
happiness
now dude it's everything there's not a
lot of people crying for pretty girls
but you're sitting here and when you
wake up in the morning you're like [ __ ]
instagrams the most important platform
right ninety-one percent of my audience
are dudes that want to see my body I
want to be known for music every time I
post music it gets no [ __ ] engagement
every time I post skin it gets
engagement and nobody's crying for
pretty girl problems but the reality is
it's your problem
it's been frustrating for sure because
like a lot of people are telling me well
mix both you know the sexy and you know
and the music so but I would like for
people to listen make up video straight
to face and like yo dudes like I know
why you're here like I get it like if
like if you've ever liked you if you
like have gotten value out of me
just put me on one time right now tag
your sister your mom your girlfriend
your wife cuz I'm about to put out a lot
of music and like I just want some of
that love people want real hey [ __ ] this
transition from model to musicians been
tough you [ __ ] don't want to
like my [ __ ] cuz I'm not giving you tits
and ass I'm [ __ ] struggling
creatively and got nothing to [ __ ]
give for you music wise like who else is
struggling today that's when you'll pop
if you're not full of [ __ ] which I
really believe it or not
then put out the [ __ ] music for a
year and then [ __ ] get frustrated at
the end of the year that it didn't
happen and then put out bikini shots but
that will like you've got time you're
not 80 yet you can like you can model
next year do you know what I mean yeah I
know so do it
otherwise you're half [ __ ] pregnant
mm-hmm half pregnant means you don't
know like oh if I went all-in that's
what you're doing when you're laying in
bed if I went all in the music what
would happen glean have you heard of
that because another kind of rouse gonna
take during my rollout to keep people
engaged and
you know keep people listening and
pretty much it's kind of like a sweet
steak type of tracker thing listen it's
not my face please really listen to me
you're looking for shortcuts your body's
a shortcut gleams a shortcut sweepstakes
or a shortcut contest a shortcut put out
[ __ ] music here's why you're young
enough to do it all in for a period of
time and then decide you know what I'm
saying
you're blessed with options Yeah right
you agree right you felt that one yeah
you're blessed with options what was me
you have to settle in in two years to
back to battling well fine so if you're
so ready now go if you're not going back
then don't be a half-assed okay Oh music
everything every day hey everybody this
is the askgaryvee show and we my show
today we're gonna be pairing wine with
three foods and by that I mean we're
going to be pairing cat wine wine made
specifically for cats with three
different food flavored candy canes
let's go here's to good health that is
atrocious pairing it with mac and cheese
candy cane that really feels like might
confuse other delicious are those oyster
will get later nary what is the largest
mammal you think you can knock out with
a single punch a pony we have some
rotisserie chicken in candy wow this
smells atrocious - exactly like it all
right how does this pair with terrible
it's kind of like a Thanksgiving at my
house
this is delicious this is delish line
just one oh this is the top I love it
you could buy the Jets right now yes
with the one stipulation that you had to
wear Jordans every single day for the
rest of your life would you do it not
yet
really really I'd wait I need final yeah
words you wanna almost everybody who's
gonna watch this is unfortunately living
their lives based on somebody else's
opinions and that leads to extraordinary
unhappiness and we need to start making
being a millionaire not the ambition but
being a happy person the ambition and
I'm really I really believe that that's
about to happen and I want to be one of
the people that drives that conversation
amongst the hundred thousands of other
people that need to do it for it
actually to become real boy do I want to
eliminate judgment everybody here is
judging people we judge so much and now
with the way modern technology works
it's so easy to judge at scale with so
little context so a little less judgment
and a little more empathy hey guys thank
you so much for watching my video on
youtube I wanted to jump in here at the
end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink thirty six bottles of wine
a year or give away thirty six bottles
of wine a year please sign up for club
empathy this project means the world to
me that could really use your support
[Music]